gang real quick before we get this
episode started summer is going into
full swing and so is the
are you garbage keep it moving 20 21
tour oh yeah we're gonna be coming to a
town near you
for a little bit of stand up and we're
gonna be answering your
garbage questions kippy tell them what
they need to know
july 14th columbus funny bone july 15
cleveland hilarities august 11th rhode
island comedy connection
august 12th left boston those tickets
are cooking that's gonna sell out
get those tickets then august 25th we're
at new brunswick stress factory and then
august 26th we're at mcgooby's joke
house in timonium
maryland right outside of baltimore i
like it gang get some ticks
come out and see it's gonna be a
fantastic fun time a mix of stand-up
comedy in the ayg game
come out and hang with uncle hank and
your aunt kippy
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals
or absolute trash now
here are your hosts kevin ryan and
h foley hey everybody out there
and welcome back to everybody's favorite
new podcast
this is are you garbage sure is it's a
little show we sit down with your
favorite comedians
and we find out they grew up to be
classy yeah or if they're just a
um what a big old piece of [ __ ] oh yeah
i'm your host age foley coming at you on
a sweltering day
down here in aunt tooty's basement she
doesn't have central air conditioning
it's a pre-war building um
she's got the window units in sure uh
i heard something what's that well
as you know our recent escapades around
the midwest uh have produced some costly
uber and lift bills sure so from what i
understand you worked out a deal with
her where tudy is now taking over the
books
i don't think so no it's not what she's
running around telling people she handed
me a [ __ ] greyhound bus ticket to
[ __ ] cleveland sure well i mean the
[ __ ] funds are a little low in that
bank account
ladies and gentlemen thank god we got
titty to watch i gotta get two seats for
the big man on delta
you know she has her associate's degree
sure from uh montgomery county community
college
in i think molecular biology okay that's
good she knows how to balance it
and she did that in two years wow that's
why i get that
real overachiever that tudy is my
co-host is coming at you from across the
uh kitchen table here uh so it's a
family yep it's just the boys we know
you'll love them the boys are back in
time
that's right we're back in town he is
the head bozo around here
so show this guy some respect and we
joke a lot but let me tell you something
kids
when you're reaching for a best pal do
yourself a favor
make it a kippy he's the guy you'd want
in the foxhole with you
kevin james ryan bartholomew ryan hey
gang happy to be here thanks for tuning
in
as always please make sure you rate
review subscribe over there on itunes
even though that don't mean [ __ ] anymore
itunes is really changing the game
there's no charts or nothing anymore
really they're gonna screw us somehow i
[ __ ] feel it
itunes uh subscribe on youtube even if
you listen
pull out that youtuber yeah click
[ __ ] subscribe
because you know why those numbers are
true almost forgot our [ __ ] tagline
uh and then obviously patreon.com which
by the way
ladies and gentlemen talk about cooking
cooking that's a michelin star chef in
there
cooking it's the hard feelings you got
to go for that value pack value pack
listen
it's you go for it and it goes all
summer long
five dollar level is great it gets you
the bonus ayg every week the ten dollar
level though
you get the video to hard feelings and
audio you get the video to the [ __ ]
to ayg yeah you're getting the goods
there
yeah hey i got a question what's that is
the is that a plate of fajitas coming to
the table or is that the patreon
sizzling it's cooking over there it's a
good time
we're not just saying that we're not
just saying that also two guys
i gotta be not the live shows are
[ __ ] bunk ghosted yeah
they i mean there's something else uh if
you're not familiar we do stand up and
then we do
we take questions from the audience you
guys submit them we pull them from the
emails and go over them with you
live it's a [ __ ] hoot atlantic city
chicago
indianapolis back to chicago [ __ ]
lights out
every time if you were at one of those
shows
we [ __ ] love you and you were [ __ ]
amazing it's so cool to
and like we meet everybody afterwards we
take pics we [ __ ] hang out
you know grab a little bit of how's your
faja whatever you need we're doing the
real thing
it's cr i was almost crowd surfed on the
last show in chicago
nice yeah nice it was great it was a lot
of fun thanks so much everybody for
coming out and we will be
in cleveland and columbus next in the
middle of july yeah
get that [ __ ] specifically
columbus
if you were on if you live in the middle
of cleveland and columbus
pick columbus okay he said if we don't
move any more tickets in columbus we're
hitching there
she goes old school yeah did you ever
hitch
uh never hitch no i mean what was that i
mean
hitched yeah i mean i know what it is
but i mean i was i grew up in the 90s
let me ask you
do you know our producer extraordinaire
t-bone mcmuffin mcmullen i forgot about
that guy cause he's the magic man
now you see him now you don't kid worked
hard over the last couple of days
running around doing his thing
we appreciate him we love him he's also
killing on stage
toby mcmullen what's up dudes hey pal
t-bone
dude those shows were [ __ ] sick
yeah it's pretty crazy it's it's wild
for us uh you know
yeah that people come out i mean we were
selling out [ __ ] two shows of [ __ ]
zany chicago
and let me say this pole town ain't
talking rosemary yeah not up there in
rosemont all right
they don't put pickle on their hot dog
up there we've been doing that accent
for the last seven days oh man it's bad
i got away from it because my girlfriend
my girlfriend my wife didn't get it nor
did my girl from
she's like why are you talking like and
she doesn't understand the chicago
accent i'd be like her doing like a
dusseldorf accent
i don't hear it yeah um so i got off it
then i met back up with you guys at the
airport and
wanted to put a gun in my mouth it
hadn't worn on us
at all people they were budgeting each
other we're at all here
yeah you can say [ __ ] uh first of all
we can only all say like six words
we got rosemont we got we took the
architectural tour on a boat in the
river
there it's all terra cotta everybody
using derrick no one i tell them four or
five times
use a limestone they say no derrick got
it terracotta terra cotta every build it
there got it there got there god
do you got a terracotta guy
we had lunch at pitillos we went to
georgian georgettes i had the steak
we didn't get the deep dish though it's
tough over there at the jw marriott
downtown first class facility i'm gonna
tell you that right now
whole building we just went a little
brooklyn too to be honest
whole building terracotta shout out to
chicago and indianapolis is fantastic
yeah indy was [ __ ] sick good good old
time at indy
we love you yeah thanks so much you know
what i wanted to ask
you what's that buddy um and i didn't
notice this until
you know i haven't flown a lot i haven't
noticed this i didn't notice this until
the second time we were flying to hawaii
right before we landed
but what's with the [ __ ] flight
attendants
going around with the pump and dump
[ __ ] credit card
run that's what they do they've been
doing that for a while you sign up with
delta today you get extra
15 000 miles up your [ __ ] blah blah
blah i almost pulled the trigger to be
honest with you
are you kidding me you've signed up for
a credit card on an airplane i almost
just did it now
garbage because they were like right
away you get 60 000 points like i should
spike your head
trash listen well yeah um
it is what it is i don't have good
credit i could use the [ __ ] we could
use the points i mean we're spending
[ __ ]
i mean take it to cleveland's like
[ __ ] 900 beans
i gotta we're flying the three of us out
you know what the [ __ ]
that got me thinking will there be a
point in the near future when we start
doing something
with our money like will we start having
the money that we're making here
work for us somewhere else like maybe
buy like uh some laundry mats or
something like that
like you're going collecting the
quarters and [ __ ]
no got a string of movie theaters
[Laughter]
adults
no i don't think we're going to get i
don't think we're at that point well
we're really good acquiring other
podcasts
and stuff
hey listen we're going to come in and
buy you out fire the lowest 10 percent
[ __ ] take 20 off the top you know oh
me i own 49 percent of buy guys
[ __ ] shell out all the assets [ __ ]
farm it out leave it
leave it a shell of itself and move on
hostile takeover yeah
um no i don't think we're i don't think
we're gonna do that i lost all my money
in a legion of skanks bump and dumb
scheme
[Laughter]
oh good stuff oh also real quick
toby please while in chicago my friend
put me to something i want to share with
all of our listeners and youtube bozos
here
oh god if you have coins you ever had a
bears game
and you're trying to smoke there's not
playing green
you got to walk out of section g there
to have a sig uh
if you have coin operated laundry in
your building you can
google the the company that makes the
machine and buy the key to the laundry
machine for like
six bucks and never pay for laundry
again just pull the corners out put them
right back in
i mean what do you want to be a dirt
bike yeah dude i'm not [ __ ]
i'm not setting up a scheme where i'm
stealing my own quarters back
all right that's insane i mean if it was
like
well if only i said laundry around him
poking holes in his business model you
want to know how to get uh
definitely get a prize when you do the
claw at the arcade
i'll tell you you press one one two two
nine nine shut up yeah we're talking
real scams here we're looking for
we're almost white collar all right
you're wide collar let me know
let me know if you find the corrupt
government somewhere on the continent of
africa that wants to play ball
yeah all right we're going to tony's
tony's gonna own a diamond mine yeah i
want blood diamonds
whatever else we can get into over there
[Laughter]
all right whoever we gotta back weapons
arms start moving yeah so like you know
government contracts
yeah that's what that's that's what we
need to do
yeah right something like that something
to move our money yeah
get in with the gangs i always wanted to
buy a motel i've been i've been kicking
around the idea of buying a motel down
there down the shore somewhere
that's good put cameras in all the rooms
motelier what a voyage warrior that
movie the warrior hotel
yeah no it was the voyeur was a movie oh
really he's gonna say it's a pretty good
idea it was a documentary the guy would
do that he would climb through the ducks
damn yeah remember you know gay perry no
not that's
uh tally gay talia talia gay
he's an actor or no he's not i'm sorry
schreier no he's
a writer he's a writer all right gay
talia italian gay something whatever
either a movie on it
okay he went out and visited the guy and
climbed through the vents and watched
like
really he was peeking too was doing
research for his book oh
yeah that's what i say yeah anytime i
get caught doing something
working on a script it's about
mcdonald's
it's about mcdonald's at midnight uh the
other thing i wanted to ask you before
we get to the patreon questions
what is um first of all the food in
chicago
was absolutely fantastic delicious sure
do you think it's garbage to stack the
plates for the waiter
yes it is for sure like when you're done
put everything
well all right hold on together let me
because i noticed that
yeah that's bad that's that's trashy
really yeah you're sitting you might as
well be sitting in the sink with all the
dishes stacked like that
get the [ __ ] out of here no yeah the
only with time you stack
is if you're making room for
other plates like if they're coming over
to drop something you take it you're
like oh i can stack this or like
whatever
if you're making room to operate sure
but if you're just like
partially busting the table just because
it's like
that's just to help him out or whatever
it's like applebee's stuff to me yeah
they don't need you stacking it you know
why it's garbage because
every person that does that goes i used
to work in a restaurant i don't know how
it is
you've been there yeah yeah i don't know
it's just sitting there with a stack of
[ __ ] plates to me is
weird and also if you got a classy
enough place they come scoop it quick
enough
they're johnny on the [ __ ] spot
johnny on the spot yeah
okay yeah yeah yeah all right yeah
that's what i figured that's bad you're
like putting like the knives in the
glasses and stuff
you can't be doing that
i give them a pre-soak before you get
them back there i will stick a napkin in
a cup
that's trashy to me garbage that's so
trashy i used to bust
that was my first like four jobs just
busting tables as like a [ __ ] 12 year
old
and even then i was like you're an ant
like a grown man would do it but you're
an ad this tip's gonna stink
i did have to work for you i put the
napkins in the cup
i love digging that out yeah then you're
like [ __ ] oh yeah you don't want to
touch it oh you don't know what's in a
napkin
it's so tricky no yes that's i've chewed
up the food and put it in the napkin
yeah if we get a bad piece you get a
[ __ ] piece of fatty chicken or
something you gotta [ __ ] put it
somewhere
man talking about the quickest way to
ruin a chicken salad sandwich
all right [ __ ] biting into a piece of
cartilage all right i'm out
yeah no stop doing that you can clash
yourself up a little bit by stopping
the the chickens i mean no the busting
of the table is a
you know classy people are going to nice
restaurants in [ __ ] stacking dishes
okay classy move is when you take the
fork and the knife you put it together
bottom right let them know that's like
the signal that you're done
sure yeah there's a code what he's
referring to is that you put it
you put the knife in the fork at four
o'clock that's to let the server know
that you're finished
and they come over and they clear it
from the right-hand side which they
should have served you from the left
surfing the left clear from the right
great okay
got that yeah i used to work as a server
so i know what it's like
here's a dollar go [ __ ] yourself first
of all i stacked here
paul you worked at bear burger okay i've
had some credited institutions that i've
worked at my young man
i'm aware devon seafood in philadelphia
fired keep going big man
20 manning grill fired
and then there was some sort of
unemployment issue i remember where
there was a court date involved and you
were freaking
out next uh marathon grill
fired as well doing pretty good so far
um bear burger
you quit that's that's a burger joint i
mean it's back to verna you fight you
got fired
or you're asked to i think you guys you
might have came to a mutual decision
that
it was no longer viable for you to be
employed there
[Laughter]
all those right i don't know if you're
aware foley's a mess of
he can't make a decision without running
by 9 000
do you imagine all the phone calls i've
gotten after those firings or those
things what now what's whatever state
you were in or whatever city local
municipality what's
i you call me like i'm the [ __ ]
unemployment lawyer what's the what's
the status on uh if you're in new york
county
and you get fired but you're asked to
leave are you allowed to collect
unemployment
every time i've been fired from a job
i've fully prepared to go to war
oh yeah to make some kind of move or
statement or whatever
which just disintegrated and i would get
cause like you believe this [ __ ]
lady's pulling this [ __ ]
i worked there for nine months on pills
every time
[Laughter]
you believe she's got the balls to
[ __ ] do this to me
after i get caught stealing from the
registers
that's not true ever stole from any
registers um
that's good i mean every time dude
you think they would pull that [ __ ] tell
you waiting tables on percocets
you're just talking about getting into
your job there's a few things better
than that
it's like a warm little blanket door
good times yeah we both took an awkward
sip
yeah we both got caught with our pants
down um
you were drifting off into [ __ ]
perkland
all right guys it's a [ __ ] family
episode
where we answer your questions from
patreon so as you know when you sign up
for patreon we will answer your garbage
question
on the [ __ ] air but we have a bit of
a backlog we promise we're gonna get to
all of them
and we love you yeah we love everybody
and also the patreon i mean you guys are
[ __ ] you guys are the [ __ ] [ __ ]
the best [ __ ] love everybody i love
anybody that's ever if you've listened
once if you've watched a clip i [ __ ]
love the [ __ ] out of you the fact that
you guys
you know dig the show so much allow us
to do this it's [ __ ] so cool i'd
forgotten that we had such a
that we had another controversial
episode
we had the one fat court the emotional
episode of fat court
sure then that hard feelings was a was a
thing
the chicago sit there chicago which we
can't talk about that's that's very we
can't even allude to what that was
no no we couldn't yeah yeah can't do
that no not
not not no not publicly honestly any
if you've came to a live show i mean
people are coming to live show they're
bringing people to the live shows and
then they're like i'm a [ __ ] fan now
i can't wait to check out the podcast
that's good times
thank you so much for everything y'alls
are the [ __ ] we're grateful and we love
you
this one home run off the bat andrew did
you have sleep apnea as a teenager
how does that even happen yeah i cause i
think it's weird
for sure i mean that i i i
i associate snoring with fat guy yeah
when it's not when
when a fat guy doesn't snore real weird
yeah sleep like a bat upside down don't
make any noise
that's weird i snored being the kid that
snores actually
snow at sleepover yeah the thing would
be like and
my problem is i fall asleep quick like
i'm out like the second one we're it's
all fun and games we're doing handstands
we're [ __ ] pulling each other's pud
whatever we're doing the second the
lights go out the head hits the pillow
two minutes in the gremlins you were out
hippies oh you put a move you if we're
gonna lay down like everybody's like on
the floor on the couch and you put a
movie up dude i'm not making it out of
the credit
i'm [ __ ] out and i'll dude i'm head
back
if i'm on a couch my head's getting
tilted back into the [ __ ] corner like
in the armrest and the cushion
mouth open and i'm [ __ ] solid really
yeah you don't sleep good enough
you're not sleeping well you're not
getting a good night's sleep i would
yeah no
for sure i wouldn't say i am as a
teenager
i gotta lose stressful life [ __ ] does
that
uh i mean you're heavy pop i'm heavy i
smoked i drank
i mean you know real sweetheart of the
kids
mommy's a little angel yeah it's a tough
look
uh snoring as a teenager and all
everybody else would be like [ __ ]
waking me up like all the other kids
like shut the [ __ ] up
i'm like hey [ __ ] dude what the [ __ ]
yeah
snore is a teenager bad luck dude i
didn't even know that was the thing
yeah it is damn how's your prostrate
straight i get on my prostrate prostate
uh
i don't know i got i mean i don't know
you should have that checked at like 22.
if you're snoring you're snoring at 14.
you're starting at 14. you got to hear
your [ __ ]
yeah there's colonoscopy at 21. at
graduation
holy [ __ ] um do you ever know anybody
that sleeps their leg bent
their knees up no
toby does oh yeah you do oh you guys
slept together oh
in the same room yeah yeah yeah man oh i
do do that
you sleep like a russian hacker
accessing pentagon codes dude his knees
are up
that's weird yeah what's that what's
that what's going on there
i don't know man i've never been
conscious for it so you seeing somebody
about that
that's weird that's your real [ __ ]
that's your
that's your real local news television
host yo what's going on with that
toby slips his knees up what's going on
there i'm all screwed up
today we have local weirdo who sleeps
when
he sleeps on his knees um i had my
roommate flip in college
uh would sleep with his eyes open shut
the [ __ ] up dude everybody knows flip
sleep with his eyes open and you know
like you're in a you're in a dorm so
it's just like two single beds like
you know all like facing each other so
like i woke up
and he's [ __ ] hey man you grab some
breath dude he's six feet away from me
like this oh my god hey what's up
i'm like flip and he's just [ __ ] dead
thousand out of dude right through him
shut the [ __ ] up and i'm like
and he's due just [ __ ] nothing it's
like sharing a dorm with jaws
and dude he's just [ __ ] you want to
hit the calf in an hour
he's just [ __ ] ice down the veins
dude so i like
wait hold on i roll over and fake sleep
i'm like i don't know what the fights go
pull the covers off yeah dude i got the
covers up to my eyes just [ __ ] hoping
this is a dreamers our father won't evan
wait a minute throwing holy water
hey father mahoney you want to get over
here hey get up there from 9 53.
[ __ ] flips at it again it's crawling
on the ceiling and [ __ ]
i'll suck your dick
get over here
[Laughter]
oh that's a good piece of business
wait does he do it all the time yeah but
that's how we woke up the only guy i
know that did it was
was my buddy brett schumer's dad but he
was like delta force and nom
well flip was not delta no um
it works at a you worked at a [ __ ]
axe throwing bar or something like that
that's what the [ __ ] man i thought you
had to be trained by the mossad to know
how to do that
talking about checking your [ __ ]
things
hey buddy try a cup of decaf
hey man you got to get to a cheesecake
factory or something
let's just let your hair down a little
bit holy [ __ ]
in your mind what's going on hey how are
finals going
gonna have a hell of a team this year
huh dude
i'm telling you when you start talking
to someone and they're just dead
and i'm dude so i did you not know it
no and i'm like i go you should have to
put that down on your door
i said hey man you're [ __ ] sleeping
with your eyes open because if i do that
sometimes you go [ __ ] heads up would
have been nice
most [ __ ] dumped in the river to
[ __ ] get rid of the evidence
score a couple straight a's huh yeah my
roommate died in college
yeah um was that real i don't they based
a movie on it i'm sure that i'm sure
they were a little more lenient
than you know i believe referring to the
film dead man on campus
yeah oh that's a great title um
yeah i wonder where they came up with it
um
that and my buddies pat my buddy my
buddy my buddy
pat's great aunt sleeps with a loaded
gun to a symbol
yeah i got a group of real cool
characters i grew up with
i'm snoring flips got his eyes open and
pat's got a revolver to his head
hey where the chicks at huh
also pat's great aunt mim would sleep
would stay at his house sometimes
because she like watched
the night terrors lady oh i told you
yeah good night no you had night terrors
nope
it was like [ __ ] midnight everybody's
sleeping i gotta get up to go to the
bathroom i go
lay back down and she's oh you're here
from the hallways
[Music]
dude i didn't sleep a [ __ ] wink that
night daddy stop me in the garage
[Music]
it sounds like a ghost getting blown
away by the wind yeah
it wasn't even like a scream it was like
an eerie
yeah i'm like give a guy a heads up you
don't have any sleepwalkers in your
family do you
um straight to the orphanage in my house
right now
nah the foleys don't like that [ __ ] i my
real superstitious i would sleep on the
i would fall asleep on the couch as a
kid
like you know anything like your
neighbors and all the kids you know
we'd be like up watching tv or whatever
and i would like pass out on the couch i
was like i don't know let's call like an
eight-year-old or whatever and then like
when they were going up they'd be like
my mom would be like all right or my
brother would be like you know like
a lot of times if my brother got the job
of like hey
my mom would be like hey wake heaven up
and you know take you know make sure he
gets whatever like
wake kevin up we're going up to bed
[Music]
that's what my family calls when you
sleep with your mouth open my mouth it
looks like you were catching fly
that's real trashy but i would fall
asleep
and i would wake up not knowing where i
am kind of or like a little delirious
and i'm real uh i'm
i'm real conv like my brother would tell
me
you go kev he's a [ __ ] jerk-off too
right so he takes any opportunity he can
to [ __ ] with you especially
so i love him and he goes he'd be like
kevin it's time to go to school so i'd
be like all right
and i would like you know get i don't
know what the [ __ ] going on i'd be on
the couch
and he would put my school bag on me
instead
and send me out to wait for the bus in
the backyard stick a pop-tart in your
hand
no and i would be standing on the deck
in the backyard at like [ __ ] midnight
waiting for the school bus
and i vividly remember like coming to be
like it's too cold to be waiting for the
bus right now
i thought the weather said it was going
to be 80 and sunny what's going on
this is a cold march so i remember being
like what the [ __ ] dude
i remember coming too and watching him
dying laughing
in the window and i look like
i remember coming and screaming like
[ __ ] freaking out
i hadn't locked you out there uh he that
little bastard
snoring um i wake up like a vietnam
vet dude toby wakes up dude he wakes up
like that like the [ __ ] russians are
already in the bunker it's [ __ ]
insane
jesus man take a [ __ ] chill
holy [ __ ] yeah toby's not the most
graceful one of the group
no yeah um jesus christ that was a home
run of a question
oh so good this one's funny no famous
franco have any
have you or anyone in your family owned
a rock tumbler
what the hell's that it's a rock
polisher yeah and i have
a rock polish yeah you're supposed to
like you buy
rocks and the idea between like
rocks or stones being polished to become
like a pretty rock
is like they're like ran underwater like
you know what i mean they're like
the rough edges are refined and they
become shiny or whatever uh-huh
it's a real goober thing when were you
doing this i don't know college
no [ __ ] i was like [ __ ] seven and
it's
me it's maybe the loudest noise yeah
yeah yeah you ever put it you put water
in a [ __ ] like water there's
something yourself like no there's like
a motor and it just
imagine turning a [ __ ] bottle full of
rocks in water
and that's what it sounds like we set up
down the basement i did it for i thought
i was gonna have like gold or something
and after 20 minutes
then my stepdad was like yeah this takes
[ __ ] four weeks to do i'm like oh
later i'm not doing four weeks
a longer time than the instant
gratification i wanted
sure i thought i was gonna be i thought
i was gonna be an alchemist like making
gold in my basement
[ __ ] prospector yeah it looks like a
tiny standing cement mixer
yeah it's like a little jig and it like
just tumbles the rocks in there to
you know refine them i guess it never i
mean i gave it like 20 minutes and i was
like yo [ __ ]
it's like sticking a jet engine in your
rumpus room
yeah what's a rumpus room it's a
playroom
rumpus room that's
sounds like we're in a place where kids
get touched yeah my kids will never be
allowed to go over to a rumpus
yeah it's family room living room maybe
rec room rec club rec room is the rumpus
room playroom
yeah rumpus room's bad what are your
parents from the 20 he's over there in
the rumpus room
yeah no that's no good trash
that's that's man you you you have some
[ __ ]
really like ancient southern
[ __ ] trash roots in you oh yeah what
was the saying your mom said
your mind does mom have some weird
saying or something like that i don't
know her i don't know
no or something you said so it was
something
it was something from like the 20s we'll
be back right after this
you have no [ __ ] details didn't
somebody say something one time about
something
rumpus ah taking a hike and you with the
[ __ ] rock time i know
not seven i got a snoopy snow cone
machine i was up and running in ten
minutes
uh cause you're going no ice straight
syrup
there's [ __ ] mainline in it who needs
this [ __ ]
i'll be in my room um all right this one
uh this was from why it be quiet new
patreon member here first question
ever painted your living room couches
my parents bought a pair of used couches
and straight up painted them with house
paint
one was yellow one was pink and they
were as rough
as sandpaper that doesn't even make
sense to me
oh jesus christ that's
i if i go somewhere where they got it if
my mom put it i wouldn't have anybody
over
no also if you're painting your couch
the people that you
throw a sheet you throw a nice sheet
down for the dog that's all right
yeah yeah yeah um also i think if you're
a kind of person who paints their couch
the company you're keeping is probably
okay with it you know what i mean like
i don't think you're inviting over like
millionaires when you just painted your
couch yeah i'd have to guess the couch
isn't in the traditional spot either
you can definitely see the refrigerator
from wherever that couch is
oh that's it yeah that's true if you
don't live in if you live in a house and
you can still see your refrigerator from
the couch it's bad
that's got to get all over your clothes
and stuff like there's no way it sticks
to the couch
put a coat of lacquer on it we'll see
like
sleeping on a park bench yeah that's
insane dude that's nuts
i mean i want to know where you're from
yeah that that's i mean that's not
i want to know that's not in new york
where are you from what do your parents
do
how many times did they fall down the
stairs yikes
um that's a [ __ ] tough one uh this is
from chris scott ever wear a davey
crockett hat
[Laughter]
now what are your what as a child what
was your davey crockett standing
were you who the [ __ ] he was do you now
yeah okay because i remember i okay i
don't
i see you in theory you know who davey
crock you know okay
there's a historical thing i thought he
was an actor
no i think david crockett somebody
played davey crockett
that's my understanding it was like a
western like davy crockett was like you
know
it was a tv show and he wore the raccoon
the the [ __ ] skin capped the
cap with the tail yeah yeah loserville
yeah and i didn't know what it was i who
what do you got t-bone it's a real guy
oh yeah no i know that's a real story
david crockett was an american folk hero
frontiersman soldier and politician he
is commonly referred to in popular
culture
by the epitaph king of the wild frontier
he represented tennessee in the u.s
house of representatives and served in
the texas revolution
um wasn't there a tv show in the 50s
yeah there was
and movies i think where this guy played
davy crockett it wasn't davey crockett
playing davey crockett i don't think
so okay um jack of all trades huh
not a big fan you know why i was [ __ ]
80s kid he was using a musket that
didn't do it for me
i i was an m16 kind of guy first of all
i mean
or laser we
we i had no idea what it was until this
this uh new family moved in on the
street
what i didn't know who oh okay this new
family of these two kids that had these
two kids moved in and my mom was like
[ __ ]
go hang up make the kids feel well you
know like
you know being like go snore at their
house for a while go see it
go away for the bus in her backyard she
was like go hang out with them and we
went over
hell of a little league player huh i
went over and they were like
[Laughter]
snoring [ __ ] the little kid that
snores
yeah i don't i mean i don't know what
you want from me you're an old
soul man you're an old soul i'll tell
you that in that bedroom tumbling rocks
that's why i drowned it was my that was
a white noise machine
drowned out to snoring i like tumbling
rocks and kitchen flies
we went over their house and they were
like oh we're gonna watch davey crockett
and i remember i remember that's that's
weird as a
nine as 90s kids for i know
throw on [ __ ] dark wing duck like a
gentleman so i go
what i remember going what the i asked
the mom in the kitchen i go what's
they were all too excited two things
cut the crust off and who the [ __ ]
standing i remember being like
why are the how are they so excited
about something i don't know i'm pr
i know turtles cartoons i know
everything
they probably didn't watch any of that
[ __ ] i knew everything was hot on
exactly i knew everything was hot and i
go is there how the [ __ ] did i
how can these people these two kids be
so excited for something i don't even
know what the [ __ ] they're talking about
right
here i know it's from 1920s yeah and
they
50s i think they ran out and they came
back
wearing raccoon skin hats to watch the
show
and gave me one and i i looked i go i'm
gonna i gotta go
i i literally went back to my mom and i
was like she's like oh what do you do
just when i'm like i can't
i'm not sitting there watching tv in a
[ __ ] raccoon skincare wow you must
have hurt those kids feelings poor
little guys
good thing you got out yeah what the
[ __ ] is sitting there
who gives a [ __ ] about that that's the
only thing you're wearing
and i'm in a rumpus room
that's how you end up in a [ __ ]
rumpus room real quick just stand here
for the pictures no thanks
yikes that's crazy yeah it was [ __ ]
but i'm thinking maybe the mom was very
careful about what she introduced the
kids to
that's fine but do that on their own
time don't [ __ ] don't throw a
seven-year-old eight-year-old me into
that mix i'm trying to [ __ ] i mean i
was like
i was already looking for bernie's to
smoke at that point true [ __ ] but
you guys keep weeding here yeah what the
[ __ ] worried about your [ __ ]
your davey crockett binge when i was a
kid we did uh sundays we would do
mass breakfast at home and the three
stooges
so we'd watch that i mean i watched a
lot of old tv
yeah that's i mean three stooges are
classic comedy i never got into those
old disney movies there's something
about them that just kind of bugged me
out like what ones
like sound and music and all that stuff
even like mary poppins no offense i love
you disney but hit the [ __ ] bricks
with that [ __ ] you think disney's tuning
in
could be they didn't make it this far
i'll tell you that much they got added
to the patreon plug
fantastic um dig our minds freely
yeah um this is from let's see
oh this is from michael got a few city
miles on me toesie
[Laughter]
wait she must have been at the chicago
show because that's a line from a joke
which is pretty cool
uh you ever cut the filter in half on a
cigarette so it hits harder
is this a joke i swear to god that's his
question and
which i've never seen until you just
started doing it that's insane to me
i agree it's also i mean here's the
thing
you're doing after-market mods to your
bernie's tough luck an associate of mine
not you smokes marble lights it's me
no it's not you who is it so i can't i
can't
divulge that is it a guy or a girl it's
a female okay
how the tits i'm sure they're pretty
nice at one time she's an older bird now
anyway so she smokes marble lights
hondos no you would think
i i now know who we're talking about
yeah
you want to retract the tits comment
yeah thank you i thought
at that at that point i still thought
you were talking about me that's why
um and i you know i was doing the the
marble i'll do the marble reds
the red label trying to quit trying to
trying to get out of here
get this off so when i'm down there
they don't really you know i the light
the lights give me like a headache
so i cut half the filter it's like the
perfect cigarette did you figure that
out on your own or did you see someone
else doing that no i figured it out on
my own
so i think he's even more trash yeah if
i get rid of this
i can get a little more of this yeah
give it some [ __ ] some of the high
heat right down the middle baby yeah
yeah that's insane i'm aware
i worry about it i've been smoking
bernie's and smoking bernies i ain't
never seen anybody do that
that's crazy and also you never have
your own scissors to do it yeah
you're asking the guy at the lobby for
the scissors
to cut my cigarette filter yeah what
does he look like he's got to look at
you and be like you know
yes they do do they yeah i pay them too
extra couple bucks in christmas yeah
yeah man that's um
[Music]
that's garbage that's real that's a
[ __ ] tough
any type of manipulation when it comes
to tobacco products
is just saying yeah from leaving your
butt out
while you're running to the store and
coming back and grabbing it or clipping
your cigarette or
[ __ ] taking a bunch of old ones out
of the ashtray and then rolling up
another one which almost makes me want
to vomit
yeah i can't be doing that what about
what about do you have any friends that
smoke black and miles coming up that
would freak them
no i don't know frequencies where you
take it out and put it back in yeah
what yeah you empty that you empty out
the you empty out the tobacco
into the tube yup and then just put what
could fit so it's like less packed
right yeah and you take the you take the
the tip off
and there's like an extra paper on there
and you pull that off the cancer paper
they called it that's what that's what
they called it often
often referred to in blunts as well yeah
yeah yeah the cancer paper never smoked
a black and mild or knew anybody that
smoked a black-and-white man
really i think that was a 90s thing we
didn't do that [ __ ] in the 80s
we would do it we were smoking benson
hedges stealing [ __ ] new ports from
our parents and stuff like that rodney's
mom would send us to the store to get
her a pack of benson hedges we'd [ __ ]
lift a couple of them
never with the black and milds well not
a good look game out that plastic
tip you got to be a pretty bad
[ __ ] to pull that off
yeah that'll be cool i know none of the
homies are fit in that description
no offense you got to be pretty cool
yeah but some of the
some of the other some of the brands
also had a wooden tip which was even
fancier you get your hands on one of
them you were pretty [ __ ] cool
like the cigarrollios or whatever yeah
trash
whatever i am what i am um
nine-year-old that snores this is on the
same same page as uh bernie this is from
matt
brand new patron here ever snuck outside
for a bernie at a family party only to
find your grandma
also sneaking outside for a burning oh
yeah yeah that's always the big
that's like a bomb when you sneak out
you see someone else snuck what are you
doing you're smoking out here oh yeah or
like you see someone going and then like
they follow you out or you follow you
and you're like i knew what you were
doing let's catch one bro you got
lighter you got them on you
that's like that's like you're teaming
up for a bank heist yeah that's like a
game of pickup at the [ __ ]
at the park that's really got a lighter
you got the bernie's all right i made an
excuse let's go
there's there's always that point and
it's kind of a
sad point where are this this might be
too dramatic where
the extended family members like what
you're talking about your aunts your
cousins or whatever
where where when you're a kid when they
start to see you just becoming a regular
bozo
you know what i mean like that again
like when you're a little kid and you
have older rail you know they want
hey he's gonna be a ball player he's
gonna be this he's gonna be there he's
gonna do this he's gonna do that
and then they realize that he's just a
regular schlub and then there's like an
acceptance of that
and i feel like when you know like when
they first like you know they see you
drinking
or you know how you smell you know what
i mean like that you smell i've gotten
the you smoke
yeah yeah and like they know they're
supposed to like yeah my [ __ ] nba
prospects didn't pan out yeah they they
know they're supposed to do something
but they just kind of let it roll it's
like yeah
you're sitting there catching bernie's
exactly hey you're going to burn them
you're going to burn them does that make
sense what i'm saying
sure yeah sure sure it's a nice thing
but it's also
sad like a little bit of a way yeah yeah
yeah i mean
sure i see what you're saying just
another schlub in line yeah
which you are yeah
[Laughter]
um all right this is a [ __ ] home run
this is from mike mourinho uh
do all of your outlets work because if
they don't
that's an issue that's a bad
bad thing yeah or else it's working if
you ever get someone else
it plug you like she's got a guy who my
mom
she at the chair electrician is like
johnny on the spot she's always doing
some [ __ ]
insurance games getting paddy
uh yeah that walgreens had it coming
i remember my last apartment was so
trashy
uh before i moved this one i guess it
was like an old building i didn't look
too
this is like i didn't notice i never
looked how many outlets were in the
place when i rented it i just like
walked yeah no
[ __ ] you had one outlet i go this is
cool i had
one in the living room none in the
bedroom that's so
and one in the kitchen what dude it was
like a [ __ ] circuit city in there
dude i was running [ __ ]
everything was on extension cords like
my phone my cell phone
would be on a 20-foot industrial
extension cord how do you feel about
this i'd be lying in bed with like an
outdoor extension cord
on my lap how do you feel how do you
feel about the outdoor extension
indoors it's a bad luck you gotta go
like the one
yeah you gotta go the white you gotta do
the the dainty one indoors they only
ever made them in orange when i was a
kid and all of a sudden they started
doing green and this and
yeah yeah yeah they were the orange was
big
yeah it's a tough look especially in a
[ __ ] 400 square foot studio apartment
did you see that thing snaking along the
wall like a [ __ ]
like a dirtbag python i dude i would do
like
it would be like sometimes when i had
the air conditioner in the
in the bedroom the extension cord would
run
to a power strip that the thing would
then go in and like the power strip
would be hanging because it wasn't long
enough to lay on the ground
so it would literally you have to like
step over it to go to the back clark
griswold
it was better come on dude it was come
on dude you just
channeled your inner surfer there god
dude you know what's
almost worse than now that doesn't work
an outlet that's too loose
where the [ __ ] falls out of it i hate it
hate it dude my boy
my boy googe whose apartment i lived in
for [ __ ] my first
five six years here or whatever he had
an outlet
that was the light was on it you know
like those like it's like the combo
light
and the outlet that's trash too yeah it
was probably left over from the 80s or
so
yeah but the panel was it was first of
all the light switch for the room was
down
on the floor because we have yeah no
what
yeah it was like down where that one is
i was at regular outlet height but the
light switch was there
and there was no plate and you would
touch it and it would
the whole harness would move it was just
sticking out and i remember like
sometimes it would spark and stuff and
i'm
like this is bad dude we gotta get this
checked out yeah
that's dangerous but i was living there
for free so you can't [ __ ] bite the
hand of fiji true shout out to gooch
nothing worse than a
[ __ ] outlet just blown out holes dude
yeah it's tough
it's a tough look we do have that at my
house where we have to have
a certain light switch has to be on for
one of the outlets to work that's normal
is it yeah that's because that's for
like a lot of living rooms have that or
even bedrooms when you go in
so you flick the light and your lamp
turns on
for the room okay the main light like
your bedroom
light if you don't have an overhead
light your bedroom light
the one outlet will be will be wired to
that switch so when you walk in you
don't have to walk over
to the corner of the bedroom and turn
the actual light off the lamp on right
and the lamp just stays on the whole
time and you operate it with the switch
let me ask you this how do you feel
about timers
on
i don't get i mean like time like what
like you're in a jacuzzi like
like the crank timer they have they have
plugs that go
into plugs that have timers on them so
your lamps and turn on
my mom's your mom with the lights or
she's a little cuckoo she's like
macgyver
there's literally ticked all over the
house sure
and like in the middle of the night you
don't know what's going on two turn off
one turns on you're like what the heck
trying to get a [ __ ] roll up over
here i'm trying to sneak out for a half
of a bernie
trying to check out my san bernardino
also yes we've been calling bernie's now
taking trips to san bernardino yep
new word for the summer catching a
bernie it's a san bernadino
only in the summer only in the summer
yeah uh
comes with a slice of lemon this is a
very bernie heavy one this is from jeff
also religious have you ever put
cigarette ashes on your forehead on ash
wednesday in order to get out of school
or work
which i don't even that doesn't even
make sense that's crazy yeah you don't
get to go home
yeah i know i guess to be like i'm going
to church so you just pop out for an
hour or two and then come back or like
hey i'm
sorry i'm late i was at church and you
just got some [ __ ] newbie ash on your
head
i don't hate it it's it's yeah i think
jc would appreciate it as well
he'd like jc liked a nice burning you
know what i mean yeah he likes a nice
move
yeah you know he dipped that for a
couple of days pop back up that keeps
everybody on your [ __ ] toes
yeah i don't hate it nah that's good
it's good
yeah um i like it
hmm let's see here
this is from paul ever ask for an
advance on your paycheck
oh yeah i don't know if i ever really
done that i did it with my
when i worked for my dad and stuff like
that yeah let me get nick you know
burned a guy on that too i think i still
love him
it's one of the jobs you were asked to
leave from
yes it was yes i remember now i asked
for a spot
i don't legally owe him that money
that's a phone call i got if
if i work somewhere and he gave me money
in advance and then i left does that
mean
i usually owe that money can you imagine
having an employee that you fire
and then they owe you money that's yeah
i'm gonna have one
when i fire him ultimately like hey
you're into me for [ __ ] 10 jihads
let's go
make good with the ghee i asked her in
advance on my pay
the butter
so it is working i it's growing i gotta
say i gotta grow it on me little ghee a
little butter you know what i mean i
don't i just don't like the way you say
it i don't think yeah you always do a
shoulder well just say yeah give me the
ghee give me the ghee give me the butter
it's good stuff some of the grease some
of the grease
a couple of clams we actually used to
call the grease
what we used to take off the top like it
was like your
closing pay at a restaurant we called
that the grease like if you and the
other server were closing together
you got like an extra 20 bucks or
something like that or you got a certain
amount that was left over
it's nice little grease anywho this
particular situation
i had asked for a advance on for my
check and then he fired me like a couple
days later i think he forgot about it
oh yeah he's on the list though i'm
going back to drop that
off i thought you did i took care of the
one
there was two no there was one i buy
my bosses next to vernon had loaned me
120 bucks just on the side
and uh i forgot to pay him how long is
that list
that there's three people on that list
everybody else and they're all
incorporated with nine other people
no no it's um
there was more but i've made all the
amends i got to take care of
the the boss that fired me
one of my boys that i owe some weed
money to for a long time
never broke my balls about it and uh
another a kid that i bought money off of
at snack
that i owe that's it it's under a g
nothing in the state of new york the
state of pennsylvania delaware
couple foreign entities
costa rica will get their money when
they get their money they're doing all
right yeah
uh what am i going to be in peru again
you know what i mean
okay this one's from jp beasley hey guys
new patreon member
uh oh this is the guy from nashville
gaming the ipa
skippy thank you it was my pleasure to
give the ipa nashville thanks for the
shout out uncle hank sorry i didn't have
a rotisserie chicken in the trunk
is that a new question no that's an
insult
[Laughter]
my question is shut up did you did you
or do you currently have a family member
that's overly obsessed with elvis
presley
because i don't that never i think
that's more of a southern thing because
we don't have it
no my buddy rodney had an aunt that
would come and stay with him for a long
period of time which that's something i
wanted to make a question
do you have you ever had do you ever
have a relative that came and stayed
with you
for like a long period of time we've
talked about that
and that's we get that probably four
times a week trash yeah it's a bad luck
so my boy rodney had this aunt that used
to come and stay with him like out of
nowhere she would just be there for like
three weeks on the lam or something
really jammed up our
schedule had heat somewhere else
something something i don't know heaped
by what but just something yeah she
would really jam up our spot
because there would the nintendo was in
the tv room
and she'd be in there [ __ ] yeah she'd
be in there holding court all day
[ __ ] the summer up
really jammy sure she was obsessed with
sammy davis jr
obsessed she carried a sammy davis
junior doll around with her
her statue yikes yeah i mean great a
great entertainer
fantastic entertainer unbelievably
talented gentleman sure
civil rights activist was he yeah i
don't know i don't know
way before my time good man
great guy no way i'm [ __ ] going
bonko's over no i don't think anybody in
my family has a weird obsession even the
whole
extended like the [ __ ] hundred of us
i mean i'm old enough to remember like
when i like elvis was still
like he was like godlike yeah like
i've missed it completely like you were
born in 86 that's what i'm saying so
it's like
those those 10 years that's everything
it was real different
awesome i had no even looking back i
just
86 you were coasting that's when the
[ __ ] eight team came out
i was back to the future you're in the
goddamn eight team
that's that's when uh i mean everything
i know was him
fat in the [ __ ] you know the evil
knievel suits that's all i know him as
i don't [ __ ] know him as like a good
i just know him like
my dad my dad loved him but not like in
an obsessive way but all those old
school guys they loved elvis
we saw an elvis impersonator in
nashville yeah did we he was eating a
chicken sandwich
remember he had the chops and the
glasses oh in the
that's a tough look yeah that like you
know
any impersonators in your family i'd
like to know that
if you have any impersonators in your uh
no no in person anybody in your family
an impersonator
in a cover band no
not i mean i think i think you've got an
uncle that plays the keyboard in the
cover
i also think my family is such
when it comes to breaking balls such
savages
like nobody could ever do that that well
you could
if somebody was like i got okay hey i
can't make thanksgiving i got to do
an appearance as elvis or what dude he
would get
[ __ ] tortured he would be ostracized
so like it's their that would never get
off the ground
let alone like i get if one of the kids
in the band is in a band like oh hey you
know we're doing the cover of like
whatever that's different than a proper
cover band
sure no i'm talking about cover band
like hey dudes in their 30s
40s yeah some floozy on the [ __ ]
backups
we got a gig coming up yeah they call
them gigs that's not like a bowling
alley or something like that no none of
that cause i remember we were born that
would be beat out of you at our house
we were blowing through jersey one time
uh new jersey
huh what nice guy
um makes a hell of an omelette blowing
through jersey one time after doing a
show at the urban saloon it was me
my girl and our good buddy misha
and uh we stopped to get a cheesesteak
at tony luke junior
sure the one on route one okay and
they're i guess that's attached like a
bowling alley or something but there was
a [ __ ] cover band
in the next room and like there's like
people in their 50s like you know moms
in there like dancing they were doing
like shitty billy joel
i was like i would blow my [ __ ]
brains out in the middle of this [ __ ]
room yeah
oh although there is that just reminds
me there's
an acquaintance of our family
like an old family friend who plays down
the street those are two different
things
what an acquaintance and a family friend
i would say this is the only guy in the
do up group is it
maybe yeah wait i told you no this is
uh this is but i keep my eye underneath
this is how he plays down the shore
at like the big thing he's good he's at
keenan's on peggy's patio from six to
seven like
and he's pretty good it's like jimmy and
the something's or something
and like they can rock i'll give them
that they rock but like they go to see
him
yeah they've been doing it they do like
weddings and [ __ ] too
it's just perfection how about it yeah
i'm not
sure just [ __ ] on it i'm just saying
that in case this comes
in case one of his kids listens or
something comes back and beat my ass how
about i'm sitting there for the [ __ ]
halfway to margaritaville and this guy
comes up from behind me and [ __ ]
wallops you got a problem with abba
a little prick huh um remember horatio
sans and stepbrothers he had the billy
joe yeah we but it was
we only did the 80s or something
they only did the doo-wop stuff ah so
good
um that's a tough look the word gig
always [ __ ]
grossed me out wait before before we
move on to the next question fully
set one off in my head that i that i
want to know if you guys have ever sure
uh have you ever
not been able to go to a state because
you have
outstanding tickets perhaps a bench
warrant
no but i'm sure you have there's certain
place there's
there's certain times i wouldn't park my
car in philadelphia limits
for sure okay yeah i put that puppy in a
garage
because i owed him a couple of c notes
uh-huh that teego that teego had some
bodies on her
that was always i don't know what's
cleaned up what's not cleaned up
and then i would get a ticket i wouldn't
be able to have money to pay for it i
would [ __ ] drive
and then go back to new york and i'd be
like oh i'll take care of that next week
never get to it and then i go then a
year went by i go and i'm not getting
the mail the mail's going to my mom's
house she who knows what she's doing
all the detailing in the world ain't
going to clean that record so i go like
i don't know if [ __ ]
i would be like i'm just putting this a
lot i don't know what i got on it but
there's some open cases
you know there was definitely open cases
on that thing a lot and
that guy's looking for yeah we were
planning a trip to wisconsin
and i asked my buddy i was like you want
to go and he goes oh no i can't go to
wisconsin for the next eight years
that's true i got a lot of buddies i got
a handful of buddies that can't go to
canada
what's a what's a bench warrant is when
you were supposed to appear in court and
you didn't uh-huh and then they issue
the warrant from the bench
what bench the judge's bench yeah it's
it's for like non-violent crimes that's
like a warrant they're looking for you
they're gonna come and arrest you
yeah like if you get pulled over and
they run like
they run your they have a bench warrant
out you got to go to jail and appear
really yeah for what could be a traffic
ticket
no it's more like not a ticket it would
be more like
uh do you think i have any bench
warrants this is just something you're
gonna
worry about now yeah oh my god the
cheese is
no you would have gotten a letter being
like hey you have to appear oh yeah
which i would have
and if yeah you can get a bench warrant
for a speeding ticket not a parking
yeah yeah yeah it's probably like if it
goes unpaid
for [ __ ] what about grinding rails at
the local parking lot
well you gotta get caught bro come on
[Laughter]
you gotta learn how to grind them rails
not gonna catch me
that ain't easy um all right this one is
[ __ ] let's crush through a couple of
here let's do it
um we're already about an hour right
t-bone yep all right cool
uh we'll just crush a few mo ah this is
from dave lewis
is it trash to add milk to the hershey's
squeeze bottle to have one last round of
chocolate milk
walking around the place like you're an
athlete i guess he means athlete because
you're
spraying it like a gatorade model i
think that's what he means
he thinks that's what athletes do which
goes to show he's probably not an
athlete
i love those squirt bottles though those
gatorade ones oh i hate oh the the big
old-school green ones yeah but if you
buy a water with the squirt bottle hit
the [ __ ] oh
i don't do i feel like i'm [ __ ]
putting uh palm olive in my makes my
teeth right yeah get out of here with
that [ __ ] i feel like a gerbil
the only one that really does it is
pulling springs and it's
the bottle size is perfect but then you
got to deal with that i just that's
what yeah do you like i want the heavy
bike bottle yeah
i don't want the [ __ ] sports squeezer
it's so funny when companies are so
stupid you know who's a [ __ ]
idiot [ __ ] i'm sorry jesus
christ did you just swallow a fly or
something what happened
press this i like because i like burped
them when i hit my i hit my nose on the
microphone that's what i said you
burped the wrong way yeah you sucked in
your burp you snored when you were nine
let's not throw judgment at each other
that's rude
which one of us has a sleep schedule on
the books what's a sleep schedule
sleep study not me they canceled it the
[ __ ] lady hasn't called me back i
ain't [ __ ] straight in this [ __ ]
physician
hear you snoring from your apartment
um snapple
yeah it has to be intentional
the plastic snapple if you're hearing me
what the [ __ ]
are you doing because you just changed
the bottles again
and it stinks even more the only way
anybody was drinking that [ __ ] because
it was in a glass bottle it made it
colder maybe they're gonna give you
kidney stones don't drink too much of it
what snapples yeah be careful well i'm
not drinking any of it now a [ __ ]
plastic bottle also i want to live in
arizona like a gentleman i want to put
this out there do we know anybody at
twisted tee
i would like a [ __ ] i would like a
sponsorship of twisted
i would like a meeting i would like to
sit down with mr and mrs twisted
if you know him and i would like a six
pack of twisted tees there that we can
imbibe
um don't get me started wait hold on
that question what was it
the hershey's yes yes no it's not trash
yeah what yes no i'm not okay
we're gonna we're gonna we're gonna
agree to disagree on this you're right
you're undoubtedly wrong it's you're not
it's just the same as putting water in
the spaghetti sauce
to get it all out of the juice no it's
not because you don't drink the you put
the
sauce into what you're cooking you don't
[ __ ] drink out of the jar why would
you worry you're drinking out of a
receptacle that's not a receptacle
that's trash is it you're drinking out
of a glass
that's not not meant to be drinking out
of a squeeze bottle it's not meant to be
drank out of it but hershey's syrup is
so classy that whatever you do with it
is gonna know
that just shows how trashy you are dude
hershey's is the best and the fact that
we still run it into cruise like this
means i don't think you understand the
show
agree with me on that hershey's is the
best bar none my mom tries to pass off
america's choice from time to time
tell her to hit the [ __ ] bricks
almost put that bro in a home you want
to do yourself a favor on a sunday night
scoop of vanilla breyer's a little bit
of hershey syrup on top
good night yeah that i'm okay with
hershey's is fantastic
you said that like you were about to lay
out something no one's ever heard of no
it's good
ice cream and the thing that it's made
for you ever have pizza on a friday
yeah a little bit of pepperoni
not too shabby nothing am i right kippy
or am i right
nothing like a pizza on a friday this is
going to blow your hair back 4th of july
barbecues christmas
presents thanksgiving turkey
um you got one more easter
candied eggs ham ah ham
um which you kind of look like right now
oh yeah shirt yeah i got a little color
that was mainly going with the shirt
yeah
honey baked yeah pineapple on me
nothing i don't think i i think it's
smart and i don't think it's class
uh trashy okay and i'll tell you what
that shows your that's very trashy i'll
tell you what else
i never thought of it when i was a kid
and now i wish i would have
i'll be honest with you you're upset i
am
that me and my brother never thought of
that
sure but also at the same time this goes
under the assumption that there's never
going to be more
chocolate syrup i've always lived by
that code
which just never came true there's
always more chocolate syrup in your life
that's a foley series
yeah that's what i'm saying yeah if
you're running a proper household you
don't need to do that you [ __ ] toss
it when it's empty and pull a brand new
freshie
like a [ __ ] jet you want to talk
about classy that's classy
drinking out of a [ __ ] mustard bottle
ain't classy did your mom have two
two two things ready to go yeah
typically because really
yeah we had one in the fridge and one
not the only one was in the fridge
what about magic shell no that was
[ __ ] that's i mean
that was that's carny [ __ ] yeah however
you only get that done at a place
yeah that was that was did you get that
do you let the trained professionals
handle that stuff
yeah okay you can't be [ __ ] doing
your own hard shells
it took me about 12 years to realize
that hersh
that chocolate syrup and chocolate fudge
were two different things
because i used to [ __ ] on hershey server
like this doesn't taste as good
as the stuff i get on my sunday at
mcdonald's which their hot fudge is
[ __ ]
i mean michelin star rated fantastic
goddamn machines down
uh you can make your own hard shell a
little coconut oil
chocolate syrup toss in the microwave
for like 10 seconds melted down no
that's crazy
who's doing that yeah we're not doing
that but we
magic show might as well have been
plutonium
and it was super expensive when i was a
kid we never got anything the
application that [ __ ] at home
never worked i feel no it did because i
got some
maybe another guy i know some people
know some people who rob some people
maybe eight years ago in the grocery
store i was like you know what [ __ ] it i
got it
it's [ __ ] unbelievable and what i did
with it well we were talking okay
well i meant in the 90s uh i'm sure
they've made
large improvements
i don't think it worked yeah like two
three billion dollars they put in the r
d on that magic sheet yeah there's no
way there's no way it's the same formula
that we're using back then
absolutely not well what i do is i just
i just take a little bit and pour it on
a plate and put it in the freezer and it
comes out like a piece of chocolate
really good chocolate too i think we're
getting the root of some of the weight
issues here
yeah sure i'm talking about it now
getting it all out there
instead of holding it in that's good
feel good
some things are left unsaid
um all right uh this one is
uh from regan do you take the safety off
your lighters
uh home run trash move home run
trash move if you're as a kid when
you're playing with for sure i get that
as an adult you're taking the [ __ ]
the safety off crazy trash
crazy you ever you ever have someone
toss you a lighter and not warn you and
then you get hit with the [ __ ] heavy
bike flamethrower you're rigged yeah
that was
oh yeah we would ring them so much they
would blow up
oh yeah jeez they would blow up in your
hands they were sketchy
it was like a [ __ ] pig welder or man
yeah when you can hear the lighter it's
a bad sign
hey buddy relax i'm trying to [ __ ]
have a bernstein over here
a couple of bernstein bears hanging out
berenstein it was either way
it was a big debate yeah yeah wasn't
there wasn't there like a mandela effect
with them got with the
with the bears as well what is the
mandela effect it was uh
berenstein versus uh
berenstein i think that's what i'm
saying there's this big debate on the
name
so mandela effect is okay that we're
gonna blow your mind
and i don't wanna answer the rest of the
questions for the end of the day so
let's just leave it at what i explained
okay
there's a large portion of the world
right of the population
who fully believes that nelson mandela
died in
whatever the year was the 80s lived that
whole truth they all experienced it
they all watched the funeral they all
this is what they truly believe
and there's nothing deciding who does it
who didn't
so there's this the idea is there's
large groups of people
that believe certain events happen and
live those events
which they never actually happen it's
called the the mandela effect
because his was when he died everyone's
like the [ __ ] i thought he died in the
80s i remember watching it
i remember doing this i remember doing
that and i don't know the real
explanation behind it
but another name nandella
uh mandela effect was with the barons
berenstein or bernstein bears
it was about the name of it yeah so the
the everyone thinks that it's
berenstein b-e-r-e-n
stein stein basically bears versus the
actual name
which is the barontaine bears berentine
bears
or the berenstain bear sorry wait so i
have that
i'm a part of the mandela effect uh
foley you're a time traveler fully
you're nelson mandela
[Laughter]
freedom for everybody ladies and
gentlemen really
yeah yeah so i'm a part of that i'm one
of the that one's like on the way lower
one it's just one of the rubes it's like
a word mispronounced rather than
[ __ ] i could have swore the announcer
said that but now back to berenstein
bears
this is what we're this is it are you
[ __ ] kidding me you think
you you go i know that's what it is
so i've been brainwashed i don't know
alien or like this is like an alternate
universe where you
that's like that part slipped through
you're living in an alternate universe
where that is the
idea or whatever and that's like that
[ __ ] synapse got
transposed i'm making stuff up now so we
go man i'm just trying to freak you out
is what i'm doing and it's working
the berenstain they were the the family
right you have cats
no yeah the parents team bears it was a
mom and dad a son
and a daughter they lived in a tree
house yeah they loved them my dad would
read those to me
woody fantastic and he always did what i
just so trashy and disgusting would lick
his finger then turn the page
and that's trashy as a six-year-old oh
i'm like dude you're [ __ ] spitting on
my book here chief i gotta take this
different show and tell
what the [ __ ] are we doing he's gotta be
back at the [ __ ] middle school
library yeah
this is a good this is a good mandela
effect question okay does the monopoly
guy have a monocle
yes he does not he does not what yeah
does curious george have a tail no
yes he does he does not what what else
i don't know having fun though uh is
there a hyphen and kit kat
no no oh well that was his fully checks
his tattoo
look at my pockets uh
mr peanut has a monocle is it
cheez-it or cheez-its cheez-it
i don't know it's cheez-it she's it
it's a cheez-it that's [ __ ] lame come
on that's
right yeah i mean we just both looked at
the box it's on set
oh [ __ ] i forgot god damn it um
all right let's do one or two more than
surroundings mountain dew d-e-w
or d-u-e mountain dew
what like you'll get your mountain dew
it's not a vengeance beverage yeah it is
your mountain is due whether you have it
or not
spit it out all right this is from big
brian from uh jersey over there big bry
shout out to big brian what up buddy
mission ac
pal have you ever rented a vehicle from
a family member
rented yeah like hey i'll give you 20
bucks if i can borrow your car
type thing no that's a bad loss yeah we
don't do that but we just had to do
because i got a little backstory i got
denied renting the car
in chicago yes you did who'd you call
who'd i call called me sure
because i got the good credit card which
i would in my credit card your credit
card
if it was paid if you had all of your
credit available
it would have been by like six bucks you
would have gotten well here's the thing
it was not i know it wasn't when i got
this little thing
see capital one and navy federal i don't
know they got something going on
but if i go on my app my credit card app
and i pay my bill
like if i pay the whole thing sure it
instantly gives me
credit like the credit's instantly put
back on my card
but navy federal don't get wise to it
for like up two three days
two three a's yeah these idiots are
looking the other way
meanwhile i'm [ __ ] stealing from
peter and [ __ ] buying a bag off a
pool
yeah yeah yeah you know so i was gonna
have to pull that move
yeah yeah but then so he ended up
writing
uh got it all toro shout out to tauros
trash yeah but it is what it is
i was petrified it was a bad car we'll
talk about it on hard feelings but
that's more hard feelings but we uh yeah
that's that's where we're at
uh patreon no patreon i'm frontal cars
off a guy in chicago
and we're driving that the [ __ ] indie
a touch which i just scheduled another
one for
cleveland to go to columbus so see you
out there
what kind of whip is it uh chevy malibu
not big
look at us cruising through the
heartland in style little [ __ ] giants
no he gotta let us he gotta let us have
san bernardino's in a malibu
is it a convertible no i don't think so
you should have got a convertible you
can get a tesla if you want we could do
whatever i mean we're taking a bath on
these two shows by the way so that's why
that's columbus and uh come see us in
columbus game
we'd love to see and bring some shampoo
yeah why
because we're taking a bath
rubber ducky would have hit harder
rubber ducky he's getting there now yeah
he's getting it he's turning up
all right let's wrap it up guys gang
listen we love you uh
great family episode great questions
keep them coming
um you got anything for them uh no guys
uh just cleveland in columbus cleveland
one day at a time yeah uh what else is
on sale we have
uh rhode island boston stress factor new
brunswick mcgoobies
uh we're gonna be announcing philly
dates and new york dates we're locking
down now
oh yeah so yeah we can't wait to [ __ ]
see if
the shows are [ __ ] hot i'm saying
that i'm biased they're [ __ ] cooking
we're having a good me and foley can
throw some heat
on stage via stand up as is t-bone and
then me and you close that show together
that's [ __ ] it's fun the questions
are great questions are people
opening up on you guys everybody kind of
gets involved it's a whole [ __ ]
great time great experience come out and
see us we love you guys and we'll see
you next week